un peu de répit ici acuña au mexique où
les réfugiés haïtiens sont traités avec
un peu plus d'humanité
les nouvelles de del rio sont mauvaises
ces ferries ont préféré ne pas risquer
la traversée de peur d'être expulsé vers
haïti et puis de toute façon depuis hier
il n'y a plus personne sous le poids
international
les réfugiés ont soit été déportées soit
acceptée le temps d'étudier leur dossier
d'immigration été inhumée lady sovereign
à 31 ans enel germain quitté du chili un
mois avec sa famille celle
arrivée ici
par bus et j'ai fait comme cinq jours
dans la forêt
5000 $ on sait que son père et lui a
coûté 5000 dollars c'est la somme qu'il
a pu économiser après avoir travaillé
quatre ans dans les champs chine-ue
g80 là bas on épouse n'aient jamais
travail nous avions dû famille haïti qui
nous ou nous envoyer de l'argent avec
mes parents et ma femme aussi alors ils
ont décidé de quitter le chili
la plupart ici on voit le peu d'argent
qu'ils gagnent elles fmi en haïti
est passé comme en
cinq ans au chili et après je pense d
colombie panama et costa rica
guatemala
attaqué qu'arrive issam excès un périple
dangereux pour denis où naquit sa
famille certains de leurs compatriotes
ils sont morts tous sont prêts à tout
pour ne pas retourner en est
là c'est vraiment terrible fourment
vraiment à
imaginer imaginez-vous
c'est
ensuite le président le premier citoyen
du pays qui le président du pays qui a
et sécurité moi
je passais timidité
malgré tout on tente de garder le moral
jessica françois a quitté le brésil car
elle n'avait plus de papiers
d'immigration
ça fait une semaine que je suis ici dit
elle j'ai peur d'aller aux états unis
car ils vont me déporter en haïti il n'y
a pas de travail pour nous là bas pas de
président c'est difficile
par la cadence au deuxième a été
mais cet arrêt à cognin temporaire un
conseiller municipal leur annonce qu'ils
vont être envoyés dans d'autres villes
du mexique et au disque et non du vent
et où est né à tapachula et vous vous
étonnez à tapachula ce pour nous c'est
très compliqué c'était minines
déportation monoprix le président
mexicain lens qu'il ne veut pas que le
mexique devienne un camp de migrants et
demande la délation une aux états unis
affirment qu'ils sont débordés par les
demandes d'asile
nous avons cinq mille dossiers à traiter
du le secrétaire de la sécurité
intérieure au mexique ballottés d'un
camp à l'autre
ces réfugiés ne savent toujours pas ce
que l'avenir leur réserve ici elle est
bonne les guerres qui sera du canada
acuña mexique